les salles de spectacle ou encore
théâtre tel que la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt la batterie ou encore le
prisme d'elancourt sont dans la tente
il se prépare à rouvrir mi mai ou à
devoir attendre la prochaine saison des
lieux culturels qui ne pourront pas
rouvrir en 48 heures ils ont besoin
d'anticiper si très clairement nous
n'avons l'information aux alentours de
la mi mai en nous informant coup pour
ouvrir 48 heures après ça veut dire une
capacité ouvrir en réalité dure
organiser les choses relancer
programmation au minimum à moi on sera
mi juin et alors je vais être très dur
lorsque je vais dire mais si on est mi
juin
je serai peut-être amené à prendre des
décisions avec les nerfs de l'encours
avec mes collègues de ne pas rouvrir
avant la rentrée c'est la problématique
elle est là si c'est reporté au delà du
15 mai je pense qu'on réouvrira en
octobre fin septembre début octobre
facile et conditions sanitaires le
permettent autre problématique pour les
salles de spectacle c'est une
perspective de réouverture en fin de
saison il est pas rare que l'activité
s'arrête vers la mi mai vers la fin mai
pour laisser place à des à des
restitutions d'ateliers pour les cinémas
comme le ciné 7 par exemple il serait en
capacité de rouvrir dans les huit jours
le lourd jeunes au top je suis d'abord
permettre de rouvrir en 24 heures mais
dans les nuages ou au maximum je trouve
normal bombay ou préparations reports et
annulations font désormais partie du
paysage culturel
une situation que le secteur connaît
depuis plus d'un an
on est passé de d'opérateurs culturels à
tireurs de plan sur la comète quoi
finalement on en passe beaucoup de temps
à ça dans l'espoir d'une réouverture on
voit là on reporte on reporte mais on
est on essaie d'être toujours prêt à
pouvoir effectivement réaccueillir le
public les lieux culturels espère ouvrir
leurs portes au mois de mai mais reste
prudent certains nécessitent une réponse
claire dont les dix prochains jours pour
enclencher à nouveau la machine